la foule a envahi le tarmac et pour
certains une journée tête en l'air à
regarder les avions ça ne s'improvise
pas là on est 7 on a prévenu bah des
sandwich jambon rôti de porc pâté
laapéro
pant le spectacle est dans le ciel
tourangeo mais aussi au sol avec une
présentation des fleurons de
l'aéronautique civile et
militaire le fait qu'il soit à terre
déjà c'est c'est assez impressionnant et
le nombre de boutons qu'il y a dans les
cabines c'est si je m' attendais pas du
tout et euh le fait que les hommes de
l'armée nous fassent la visite nous
explique tout ça c'est c'est vraiment
très intéressant pour ce centenaire les
spectateurs ont eu droit à un plateau
aérien de choix avec une centaine
d'avions de toutes sortes des
hélicoptères des parachutistes pour le
plus grand plaisir de tous j'ai aussi
bien aimé quand quand il quand les
avions il se mettaient à l'envers et il
tournaient il se croisait c'était rigolo
ça me rappelle mes ma jeunesse que
j'étais engagé ici j'étais comment
mécanicien avion pendant 3 ans donc dès
qu'on peut revenir voir ça nous rappelle
les souvenirs avec l'annonce du départ
de l'école de chasse ce pourrait être un
meeting d'adieux mais le succès
populaire de cette manifestation donne
aussi un argument pour garder la place
de cette base militaire dans le paysage
tourangeau si certains sont gênés par
notre activité et voudraient clairement
et je que que cette activité s'arrête un
c'est effectivement ça permet de montrer
que les gens qui nous sont attachés son
sont relativement nombreux également si
la vocation de l'armé de l'IRE n'est pas
dans ce type d'événemen cel le succès du
meeting a remis du bom au cœur au
personnel mobilisé